please rise salute and show your
appreciation for the one and only
mr longclaw this was nol clark
receiving a lifetime achievement award
from the british urban film festival in
2019
just hours after the guardian last week
published allegations of abuse against
the actor
he was stripped of the accolade by its
founder
our association with noel started and
ended
when we gave the honorary award so when
when i was aware of the article
in the guardian i was in complete shock
emmanuel anyama sigue whose festival was
partnered with bafta
has now severed all ties with the
organisation for honoring clark with an
award despite having received anonymous
and third-hand allegations against him
and is calling for the chair kris nenju
majumdar to resign
chris cannot continue in his post
because
him being there him remaining there just
sends
completely the wrong signal because
whichever way you look at it bathroom
just dealt with this
horrendously and he has done arguably
some
very good work around diversity he has
um been instrumental in turning it
around in many years
for nothing it cuts from nothing i feel
completely let down
they also say that they received no
first-hand accounts
and had the victims gone on the record
to them as they did with the guardian
they would have suspended
knoll's award immediately they wanted
first-hand accounts they say
but the problem i have with that is not
only are you not meriting the
allegations
when they first came to you directly
through anonymous emails
you're now not meriting this letter that
has come from people that you have
worked with
or dealt with previously at bafta
so what are they to make of your kind of
reaction
to them for the first time since news
about clark
and bafta broke bafta has given an
interview to clarify the timeline of
events
and defend its decision to proceed with
the award
if we had had one fraction
of the information that the guardian had
we would never have given an award to
noel clark
that is that is obvious but we didn't
have that information
the first time we saw the actual
allegations against him was when they
were published by the guardian newspaper
and as soon as we saw the allegations we
suspended the award
i mean there will be a lot of people
listening to this who will
say you had heard allegations even
if they weren't first-hand you were
certainly aware that allegations were
being made against him we were aware
that people had spoken out against
noel and had made assertions
that he had not behaved correctly
but they were very generalized and they
were in the main
totally anonymous uh there was never we
were never in the position of having a
first-hand testimony from anyone
about what he had done or when he'd done
it we've been speaking to the head
of the british urban film festival who
has called for the chair of
bafta chris magenda to stand down to
resign
saying that the buck starts and stops
with him
what's your response to that well this
whole
affair has been extremely difficult as
you can imagine for everyone involved
and krish has worked uh
all the way through um together with
the board it has been a um a joint
uh decision-making process chris has not
been doing anything on his own
so any criticism that can be leveled up
after should be levelled at everybody
it is it is really uh i think not right
to single people out
but you know everything that chris did
he did with the full endorsement and
knowledge of the board
and um you you stand by both krish and
amanda berry to stay in their positions
absolutely yeah whatever the
ramifications for bafta itself
what is indisputable is that women were
too
frightened to come forward sooner
leaving huge questions for the industry
as a whole
lucy cossa sky news